rogers and lefleur
rogers and the floor
they need some audibles
at the line of scrimmage
rogers and the floor
ah
it's kind of trippy man
that's uh that's kind of wild yeah um
makes me want to do things you know i
don't know
makes me feel it makes me feel like i've
done things
but uh that's the rogers and lefleur
conundrum and tonight in in the friendly
confines of winnipeg manitoba we may or
may not see aaron rodgers place in
pre-season football we saw him walking
through the airport in winnipeg on
wednesday night with the canadian tuxedo
jacket the denim pants the denim shirt
the bolo tie your favorite mustache you
love that mustache oh my gosh it's so
bad it's so bad it's good uh i could
never wear that outfit i know that
hey i tell you what here's a dated
reference he looks like the cop from the
village people yeah you're right
mustache in those sunglasses very much
so you're exactly right hey he's got his
own unique style and he certainly
doesn't give a damn what we think uh and
when you're aaron aaron freaking rogers
you can you can get away with that every
now and then all right is he going to
play tonight i think he is i would
expect him to be out there uh you know
again i don't think it's going to be a
long extended period of time i think
it's two drives no matter what i think
one thing we're continuing to see here
in the preseason and this is something
that happened last year
teams that think that they're in the
super bowl window or their team is
really good they just don't want to play
starters or play players a lot in the
nfl and then you know in nfl preseason
games but i do expect him to get out
there and kind of just get used to
orchestrating the offense and we'll see
him out there for one or two drives i
don't think he's gonna play i think he's
gonna back out something we need to have
a friendly wager on this i don't think
he's gonna play okay i think something's
gonna happen and he's not gonna play
tonight all right let's wager how about
if he plays you have to button your top
button tomorrow morning okay no okay
well fine then the hell with you okay i
tried to have a fun wager and now you're
not having fun all right if if i had the
ingredients of the canadian tuxedo i
would do that tomorrow but i don't have
a bolo tie i don't i do have a denim
jacket floating around over there
somewhere i'm up here in my attic and
there's an old denim jacket that i think
still fits me from the 80s maybe i could
try to pull that off or you have to wear
like an aaron rodgers jersey i would
like that too that would be great do you
think i do of all people
in existence now in the world of all
seven billion people do you think i own
an aaron rodgers jersey no i don't but i
think you do live close to a sports
store maybe could get it done to where
you know you might you might be able to
pull one out and wear it tomorrow this
is this is steelers country i got a
better chance finding a chris sims
jersey here than i do in aaron rodgers
that's false no you don't
all right uh next game on the dock at
giants at the bengals daniel jones this
is his opportunity to continue this path
toward the fans saying we want jones we
want jones what do you expect him to do
tonight well i continue to expect to see
the guy we've been seeing so far who's
you know looks like he physically
belongs mentally understands where he
wants to go with the football i mean has
a good presence about him he's been
aggressive to this point uh it is it's
all positive giant's nation's got to be
happy about the way he's played and
looked they also should be happy with
the way eli manning looked eli ain't
gonna go down without a fight i i've
been impressed just with the way his
body looks and the way the ball came out
of his hand last week uh so i i mean
he's gonna fight him off but either way
for the giants this is like a win-win
situation type of year it really is it's
okay eli plays good maybe they're in the
playoff conversation i don't know if
they necessarily get to the playoffs i
don't think i can believe that
or okay things are not that great and
the team's kind of falling apart and
they're two and four okay we throw in
the future in and get to see him and i
think you know giants fans are are kind
of excited either way uh that pendulum
goes there and that and that one yes the
pendulum does swing
haven't we already you know we've been
doing this show so long together we're
circling back around to words we've
already clarified and we're doing it
again uh we talked yesterday about the
fact that that this baker mayfield
escapade regardless of how it happened
why it happened it's actually
contributed to this this notion that
daniel jones is like a sympathetic
figure and the fans the giants fans are
taking ownership of this guy and and
they they want him to do well now and
what a far cry from the aftermath of the
draft when they all were complaining
about daniel jones now i feel like they
want to see him succeed chris he's he's
done his talking on the field and he's
changed a lot of people's minds up here
in the new york area where they're
excited to see what this guy can do when
live bullets start to fly and things
like that and he gets into regular
season football he's handled himself
absolutely perfect in the situation even
with the baker mayfield comments and yes
with everybody piling on and him showing
that he's a little resilient here and
he's fighting back you know new yorkers
like a good fighter and uh daniel jones
has gone a long way to win over a lot of
people up here in this area
ravens and eagles get together in
philadelphia i remember a ravens eagles
game from back in 2001 or thereabouts
when they canceled it because the
condition of the old green cement at
veterans stadium was so horrendous but
tonight carson wentz i think we do not
see him that backup quarterback job in
philadelphia now in the hands of josh
mccown who just signed over the weekend
how much can we expect to see mccown who
was retired as of saturday show up on
thursday night and actually run that
offense yeah well he's got it's it's a
west coast language type system so you
know again it's he'll be able to process
that is he going to be perfect you know
hey uh it's like this you know
double slant might have been lion and
his old offense now in this new offense
it's bangle instead of lion right it's
the little things like that that i'll
have to reorchestrate in his brain but
i'm with you i don't know if we see
carson once either again this is another
example of a team that the philadelphia
eagles they're a super bowl contender
not sure they're not going to be my
super bowl pick in the nfc but they're
certainly in that conversation and yeah
i i can understand a guy that's not been
healthy has had some issues and now you
got the big bad baltimore ravens coming
into town who might want to do some
extra creative things in preseason game
number three just to get their defense
rolling and things that could be a
dangerous formula and i i am i'm kind of
expecting not to see carson wins tonight
patriots had their first two preseason
games on the road bill belichick very
big on trying to turn things around for
a team that was three and five away from
home last year they come home and
they're playing a panthers team that you
know this is another reminder to the
patriots that to the extent they think
they run the league the panthers run the
patriots right i don't know how much
we're gonna see ones on ones especially
cam newton they keep telling us cam
newton's gonna play chris he's yet to
play should we expect to see cam newton
in that new throwing motion tonight i do
i think we're gonna see cam newton just
because of because of that throwing
motion uh and he's gonna probably wanna
test it out and just get a feel for it
and live game action do all that but the
carolina panthers uh i think you agree
with me are one of those teams i say
watch out for this year you know they
were right in the thick of things and
playing some really good football last
year until cam newton got hurt and they
were just never the same but they got
weapons they got a supporting cast
around cam newton
maybe as good as i've ever seen on that
side of the football norv turner's
really found a a good formula for those
the skill set of a lot of the guys they
have there and curtis samuel dj moore
their o line is better so i think this
carolina's going to use this as a test
knowing hey it's new england let's see
what we got against you know the best
and uh they're gonna try to build on
that
yeah panthers got splattered on that
thursday night in pittsburgh and never
recovered from it lost seven in a row at
a time when they were six and two i
remember for the first half of the
season we were looking at saints
panthers playing twice in the final
three weeks this season possibly
deciding the one seed definitely
deciding the division and then the
panthers just disintegrated before our
very eyes for the patriots well hashtag
tommy in his new helmet i mean do we
need to see tom brady in the preseason i
mean we don't need to and i have no feel
for whether he'll play or not or do
anything like that i mean i wouldn't be
shocked if he got out there just for one
series just to kind of okay let me get
out here and get used to some people
flying around me but i don't expect it
to be anything long or you know more
than that maybe two series but the
patriots are on another level their
offense is executing at a very high
level already we've seen that from what
the other quarterbacks are doing there
too and i'm sure they've been pretty
good in practice to where they feel
pretty comfortable about hashtag tommy
all right washington plays the falcons
in atlanta and it's looking like case
keenum is on track to be the week one
starter jay gruden said monday he's in
no rush to make a decision well you need
to get in a rush to make a decision
because week one is looming could dwayne
haskins just come out tonight and just
blow the doors off of the falcons and
jay gruden wake up on friday and say
this is my guy i don't know if that'll
be enough at this point you know there's
been some really good from dwayne
haskins and you know i think you agree
where we've gone wow look at that throw
ooh he moves better than i thought and
all those type of things but there's
still been a lot of you know whoa he's a
rookie whoa he's raw he only played one
year of college football and i can't
imagine that that's
giving the coaching staff a whole lot of
confidence there i think it's case
keenum all the way uh i don't even think
a spectacular performance by dwayne
haskins tonight and just an average
performance by case keenum is gonna get
that done if dwayne haskins starts at
quarterback this year for the redskins i
don't think it'll be one of those things
where it's about the halfway point of
the year to where they feel he's
comfortable with everything he got to do
uh in the huddle at the line of
scrimmage and all those theatrics
jaguars and dolphins get together in
miami off the field it's jay-z versus
nos on the field it's ryan fitzpatrick
versus josh rose and fitz getting the
start in the third preseason game but
that doesn't mean the competition is
over
and again i mean
you've been through this before you've
seen competitions in training camp how
much does that third game of the
preseason truly go toward pushing the
dial one way or the other for who's
going to get the starting job yeah this
is it this is the biggest the biggest uh
what do i want to say test or you know
just
dress rehearsal for the coaches to feel
comfortable about that situation you
know if one guy outperformed one guy in
pre-season game number one the other guy
guy one appreciated in game number two
preseason game three is not only going
to be like the the tiebreaker but it's
got a little more
influence than the tiebreaker because
usually you play a team that's going to
play their starters a little bit more
there's probably given some conversation
between the coaches hey we might game
plan a few things this week so there's
that aspect of it too but i'll say this
i don't know where this quarterback
situation's gonna go in miami josh rosen
when i broke down the film last week
mike it was more impressive than maybe i
was led to believe watching highlight
shows around you know on tv and
everything everybody likes to show josh
rosen's bad place he made a number of
good throws and good plays in the pocket
last week i think this is very close and
i think tonight could go a long way to
to determine who is that week one
starter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports